the clark county division of family
services the sponsors of this next
segment is doing what they can to help
the foster youth in our area here's how
you can support during national foster
care month and beyond
foster care is a cause that the clark
county division of family services tends
to year round but especially in may may
is national foster care month and this
is a time that we are able to bring
attention to the need for foster
families for our foster youth and care
we currently have in clark county 3 000
children in foster care and less than
500 foster families available for them
and for potential foster families
jennifer erbs and her team are here for
you so we are currently here at our
resource center
this is where we provide foster parents
with their initial training
our foster parent champions are here at
this facility as well and in the same
location is peggy's attic which is our
donation center which allows us to
provide
initial clothing for foster parents who
first get a placement
we
have opportunities to sign up for an
information session at
clarkcountyfostercare.com
if you're interested just to hear the
information about what you need to
become a foster parent and who is
qualified to become a foster parent so
to become a foster parent you really
just need to have some patience and
understanding of some trauma that some
of our kids are going to go through
you have to be at least 21 years old to
be a foster parent
you can be single or married you can be
in an lgbtq relationship
you can live in a condo
rental or own your own home
you're able to
have transportation to be able to get
our kids to and from the needed
appointments for them
you have to take nine weeks of training
pass some background clearances
and have our workers come out to your
home to do a home study
to make sure that we're getting quality
families for our kids once you pass your
training the help from the division of
family services does not stop there we
have foster parent champions who are
foster parents
currently or have been foster parents
that you can call and they can help walk
you through a crisis or refer you to
services in the community
peggy's attic again is a great resource
for
clothing we also have hannah's closet
which is a partner in the community
also
to help with
clothing or additional resources our
licensing workers are available to call
if you have questions if there's
concerns about what's going on in a case
we're available to
meet with our families quarterly were
available for them
any other time that they need questions
answered regarding their kids and of
course fostering is a huge commitment so
if you're not ready or able but still
want to give back to foster youth you
can donating to peggy's addict being a
mentor for kids you can be a casa worker
where you can volunteer
and help kids through their foster care
journey you can also support the
division of family services special art
project by local artist darian deenan
the project is traveling throughout
clark county spreading awareness about
our traveling foster youth starting in
may and going all the way through the
summer so the exhibit visualizes the
wishes of children currently in foster
care and those in need of a foster home
so at the end of the day the number one
qualification for a foster parent is
love our our children are traumatized
they have to be ripped out of a home
that they
thought was their own
and they have to be placed into a
stranger's home and so understanding
what that must feel like for a child is
really important
thank you to the clark county division
of family services for sponsoring this
segment for more information call 702
702-455-0181
or visit clarkcountyfostercare.com